>> Tucker: AND WE TOLD YOU A
FEW MINUTES AGO THAT THE MOST
ROBUST SECTOR OF OUR ECONOMY,
THE ENERGY SECTOR, HAS BEEN
WITHERING THANKS TO THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION, BUT THAT IS NOT
THE ONLY PART OF OUR ECONOMY
THAT IS IN TROUBLE.
FOR GENERATIONS, AMERICA
PRODUCED THE MOST AND THE BEST
COMEDIANS IN THE WORLD.
THIS WAS THE FUNNIEST COUNTRY ON
EARTH BECAUSE IT WAS A FREE
COUNTRY.
COMEDY REQUIRES ABOVE ALL
INDEPENDENCE AND HONESTY.
YOU CAN TO BE READING TALKING
POINTS FROM ANYBODY.
YOU HAVE TO BE TELLING THE TRUTH
ABOUT THEM, THAT IS THE WHOLE
POINT.
AND THE SECOND YOU START SUCKING
UP, YOU ONLY HUMILIATE YOURSELF.
LATELY ON TELEVISION THEY'VE
BEEN SUCKING UP TO PEOPLE IN
POWER FOR YEARS NOW.
THEY HAVEN'T RESIGNED THEIR JOBS
BECAUSE THEY PAY WELL BUT THEY
DO CONTINUE TO HUMILIATE
THEMSELVES.
IF YOU'VE TURNED IN AT ANY POINT
OVER THE LAST YEAR, YOU SAW
THINGS LIKE THIS.
SPEAK OF THE CUOMO BROTHERS, YOU
AND CHRIS, TIDE IS THE MOST
DESIRABLE MEN IN NEW YORK.
AS AN OLDER BROTHER, CAN YOU
ABIDE BY A TIE?
DO YOU WANT TO DO ANYTHING RIGHT
NOW TO PUSH YOURSELF OVER THE
TOP IN TERMS OF DESIRABLE NETS?
A SMOLDERING STARE, ANYTHING?
>>
I HAVE A FRIEND COME I WON'T SAY
HER NAME, SHE WANTS TO
KNOW WHAT PHASE OF DATING ARE
YOU CURRENTLY IN?
ZERO?
>> I AM PHASE ZERO ON DATING.
THERE IS NO DURATION ON PHASE
ZERO.
THERE IS NO AUTOMATIC TIME BUT
TO GO TO PHASE ONE, YOU COULD
STAY IN PHASE ZERO FOR MONTHS.
I THINK NEW YORK CITY WILL BE
FULLY REOPENED BEFORE I GIVE
OUT, BEFORE I GIVE OUT --
>> Tucker: SO AWFUL TO WATCH,
THE FAKE, OVEREAGER LAUGHTER.
THE STUPID LINES, THE ENDLESS
SUCKING UP AND THE SADDEST PART
IS SOME OF THESE GUYS, THE
PEOPLE YOU JUST SAW USE TO BE
LEGITIMATELY TALENTED.
THEY WERE FUNNY.
BUT THEY GIVE IT UP IN ORDER TO
READ THE SCRIPT.
SAD AS HELL TO WATCH.
LAST NIGHT, THE NEW VERSION OF
THE SCRIPT TOLD THEM YOU BETTER
CHANGE YOUR OPINIONS ON
ANDREW CUOMO.
NO MORE SUCKING UP.
SO, DUTIFULLY, THEY DID.
>> IT WAS A BIG DAY IN NEW YORK
HAS ANDREW CUOMO ANNOUNCED THAT
HE IS RESIGNING AS GOVERNOR.
DURING HIS REMARKS HE SAID IT
WAS BEST THAT HE STEP ASIDE AND
THEN EVERY WOMAN IN THE ROOM
TOOK TWO STEPS ASIDE.
[LAUGHTER]
AFTER HIS ANNOUNCEMENT, CUOMO
SAID HE IS STEPPING DOWN IN 14
DAYS.
I'M SORRY, IS THIS REALLY A TWO
WEEK NOTICE TYPE OF SITUATION?
BEAUTIFUL DAY IN
NEW YORK CITY, 85 DEGREES, 75%
HUMIDITY, AND THIS AFTERNOON,
ANDREW CUOMO RESIGNED.
[APPLAUSE]
DON'T LET THE DOOR HIT YOU ON
THE BUTT ON THE WAY OUT, BUT IF
IT DOES, THAT DOOR SHOULD ALSO
RESIGN.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Tucker: DO YOU THINK HE
COMES HOME AND HIS WIFE SAYS
"GOOD JOB, YOU'RE REALLY FUNNY!"
NO SELF-RESPECT AT ALL.
MARK STEYN HAS SELF-RESPECT AND
CLARITY AND HONESTY AND ABOVE
ALL, PERSPECTIVE ON THE WORLD SO
HE IS HILARIOUS BY DEFINITION.
HE JOINS US NOW TO ASSESS WHAT
HAPPENED TO EVERYBODY ELSE.
MARK STEYN, GREAT TO SEE YOU.
HOW SAD DID THAT MAKE YOU
WATCHING THAT QUESTIONING SOME
OF THOSE GUYS WERE LEGITIMATELY
TALENTED AT ONE POINT.
>> AT ONE POINT BUT HAVE GOT TO
SAY AFTER THOSE LAST CLIPS YOU
PLAYED OF COLBERT AND FALLON,
SAY WHAT YOU LIKE BUT THAT
CUOMO-SEXUAL CONVERSION THERAPY
REALLY WORKS FAST.
THEY TURNED IT AROUND, THEY WERE
FULL ON CUOMO-SEXUALS AND NOW
THEY ARE DOING CRACK ATTACK
MATERIAL, WHAT WAS THAT LINE
THAT HIS WRITERS WRITE FOR HIM?
CUOMO SAID HE WAS GOING TO STEP
ASIDE AND THEN ALL THE WOMEN
TOOK TWO STEPS ASIDE.
IT'S AMAZING TO ME THEY HAVE
LIKE, 37 WRITERS ON THE WRITING
STAFF AND THEY MET FOR HOURS AND
THEY TESTED THOSE LINES AND
THAT'S THE BEST THEY CAN COME UP
WITH?
YOU HAD TO SEE THE PROBLEM FROM
FALLON AND COLBERT 'HIS POINT OF
VIEW.
THEY CAN'T DO ANYTHING GENUINELY
FUNNY ABOUT THE GUY BEING A
BLOODSOAKED BUTCHER, THEY CAN'T
DO ANY COMEDY ON THAT, THEY
CAN'T DO ANY COMEDY ABOUT HOW
PITIFUL IT IS THAT THEY ARE ALL
GOING ON ABOUT HOW SEXUALLY THEY
HAVE THE HOTS FOR HIM AND THE
CUOMO-SEXUAL COFFEE MUGS WHERE
HE IS BARE CHESTED AND THEY HAVE
FALLEN FOR AN OBVIOUS RACKET
BECAUSE THE LAST THREE GOVERNORS
OF NEW YORK, ALL DEMOCRATS, HAVE
NOW ALL RESIGNED IN ONE SEXUAL
SCANDAL AFTER ANOTHER.
YOU COULD DO SOME JOKES ABOUT
HOW SPITZER NEEDED A ROOM AT THE
MAYFLOWER IN WASHINGTON, D.C.,
AND THAT IS LIKE, 1,000 BUCKS A
NIGHT, AND THEN DAVID PATTERSON
MADE DO WITH THE DAYS INN ON
94TH STREET IN MANHATTAN AND
THAT IS ONLY $130 A NIGHT AND
THIS GUY SAVES YOU THE HOTEL
BILL ALTOGETHER BECAUSE HE JUSTE
OFFICE, BUT THEY CAN'T DO
ANYTHING.
EVEN WITH THE 37 MAN WRITING
TEAM.
AND I FEEL MOST SORRY FOR MY
DEAR COMMONWEALTH COUSIN, TREVOR
NOAH FROM SOUTH AFRICA WHO I
ONCE SAW AT THE LONDON
PALLADIUM, AND HE WAS MARGINALLY
LESS UNFUNNY, AND WHAT'S
INTERESTING IS THAT 10 MINUTES
AFTER LANDING AT JFK TO GET HIS
BIG JOB ON THE COMEDY CHANNEL,
THIS GUY WHO'S GOT ALL KINDS OF
INTERESTING PERSPECTIVES,
SOUTH AFRICA VIA LONDON AND ALL
THE REST OF IT, HE IS SUDDENLY
AS INTERESTING BORING AS ALL THE
REST OF THEM.
IT'S THE DEATH OF COMEDY.
IT'S NO LAUGHING MATTER.
>> Tucker: IT'S TOTALLY
SOVIET.
THEY WEREN'T VERY FUNNY, EITHER.
MARK STEYN, GREAT TO